could pick five people from any time
period in the world that had dinner with
Jesus Marcus Aurelius Buddha Elon Musk
Rockefeller you can probably wait what
I'm interested in by how I put people at
the table three out of the five are like
spiritual life wisdom philosophical
people and then two of them are business
one is eternal business which would be
Rockefeller just be interested because
he was like richer than any person who's
ever been and then I would still have
Elon at the table because he might be
the only one who could apply all that
stuff to today so that would give me
like the all-time goats and then some
element of application that I could use
it today